in 2020 we made videos about the game of
thrones books a song of ice and fire
including euron's apocalypse the dawn
plot
and dunkin egg we covered westworld
season 3 and the new watchmen
and raised by wolves and the expanse we
made a non-fiction video about
disaster and religion and zombies and
there was that cookie thing in 2021
we'll keep making song of ice and fire
videos with more theories recaps and
analysis
we'll cover the game of thrones prequel
show when it comes
and hopefully someday we'll do the winds
of winter too
and we'll keep covering new series
they're making a show
of foundation by isaac asimov so that'd
be cool to cover we could do some his
dark materials
or american gods or the boys or more of
the expanse
they're making shows of sandman and the
stand and why the last
man there's the june movie and the
matrix iv
coming we could go back and do dark or
devs
and maybe more non-fiction videos about
history and myth and stuff
there's a lot to choose from so we're
holding some votes on patreon
there's one vote to choose a song of ice
and fire video topic and one vote to
choose a new series
these votes are open to all patrons on
all tiers and the votes close
in a week so for a few bucks you can
support alt shift x
and help choose some new videos at the
link below
either way thank you for watching and
happy new year
special thanks to patrons cameron weiss
michael lapel
ryan steele triangle wine company harry
nicos moritakis shane veglia brian
sentient ria mcdoodle
and tim kniff cheers